I mean not many shows or books have the
guts to kill a ten-year-old let alone
yeah after them catching an incestuous
relationship that's true
probably more surprising in the book
where Chris he's the first viewpoint
character you know he's the viewpoint
character of the first chapter and then
we switch wait a couple of you points
don't come back to him but since he was
first I think the the assumption of most
readers is that he's going to be you
know the main guy through that and then
suddenly you think he's he's dead or
maybe he's dead but we find out more
later but you know it's what I we we
write what we want to read and I as I
said a minute ago I don't like stories
of books that are too familiar they're
too predictable
that I feel like I read a thousand times
before so I want to keep you on edge and
surprise you and make you think that no
one is safe and that was that was
certainly the intent there and that
scene has I think gotten a lot of people
hooked on these books and said you know
I I thought I was reading just another
fantasy - I hit that scene and then I
realized that this was something a
little different so so that moment has
worked very well for me it's I mean it's
an interesting point because you know in
the 60 odd years since the Twilight Zone
these sorts of stories have really
gained an enormous foothold in popular
culture you know you look everywhere
from the literary world to movies to
television to videogames to everything
it's you know fantasy stories
superheroes these sorts of stories that
are so dominant why do you think we've
seen such as such a dramatic shift in
terms of acceptance and speaks of
conquered the world actually I'd yes
doing an injury yesterday I one of the
reporters interviewed me said he we his
TV station specializes in in geek and
nerd culture and it really took me back
to my own house
school days we're a deacon nerd we're
not things that you wanted to be called
and now they've become you know proud
badges of a group that has a culture so
you know the world really has changed
you know my father called the list of
weird stuff you know he couldn't
understand why this interesting weird
stuff science fiction fantasy horror
because it wasn't like real he liked
westerns which of course as we know
we're very real all those gunfighters
meeting in the center of the street to
practice their quickdraws yeah that
would happened every day I don't know
but it's nice to be part of the the
culture that has that has conquered the
world and taken over popular
entertainment I I think there's these
are all flavors of of imaginative
literature to put it in a room of the
Romantic tradition as another way to put
it as opposed to realism which in a
great literary tradition I think split
off at the and to end in the 19th
century in the be in 20th century and
into two currents one of which was
considered more respectable than the
other the the realistic tradition became
the literary tradition and all the genre
fiction which followed the Romantic
tradition sort of that shuffled off into
ghettos but it still appeals much more
to to a much larger audience and science
fiction and fantasy especially as the as
the world has shrunk around us and with
the television news and and you know our
technology there's no longer you know
lost cities in Africa or the exotic Far
East or all of these colorful places
where old adventure stories used to take
place these these corners of the world
all now have you know Starbucks in them
and so we go to outer space and we go to
realms of the Hyborian age or middle or
or other alternate worlds to define the
kind of color and the end a verb that we
used to get out of romantic there were
the tradition of Romanticism and
adventure stories and things that people
like Robert Louis Stevenson wrote and
yet in even in your stories these
imaginative stories there is a sense
that there's a grittiness there's our
there's a realism to the characters in
the situation's well you know I think
the characters have to be real
characters to my mind at a heart of all
of all fiction and characters fascinate
me you've been being fascinate me and
and always have there's such wonderfully
perverse and contradictory you know
creatures you know my quarrel with a lot
of a lot of fantasy as it as it was
written particularly by the Tolkien
imitators not talking himself but the
the writers who followed him into high
fantasy in the in the seventies and
early eighties was that they they
presented a very simplistic view of
human nature and you know the war
between good and evil as a subject for
for fantasy I think is legitimate for
the subject for any fiction but to my
mind a war between good and evil is is
not fought between armies of heroes and
white cloaks and armies of really ugly
guys in black cloaks but rather is
fought within the individual human heart
in in the choices that that we make in
times of crisis I mean I think all human
beings have within them the capacity for
good and the capacity for evil and in
fact we're all you know I look at
history and all of the greatest heroes
have have flaws all of the greatest
villains have moments of humanity or
redeeming qualities about them and to my
mind that doesn't make them less
interesting that makes them that makes
them more interesting